une poignée de main un premier contact
face à face avec des agents du
département
voilà où commence l'insertion
l'insertion est l'une des compétences
principales du département raison pour
laquelle près de 500 agents sont engagés
quotidiennement dans ses projets de vie
préliminaire à tous les bénéficiaires
des minima sociaux l'inscription à la
caisse d'allocations familiales
petit rappel il y a deux types de
bénéficiaires du rsa socle pour les
personnes sans aucune allocation est
sans emploi socle majoré
lorsque l'on ajoute l'allocation parent
isolé et depuis le 1er janvier la prime
d'activité a remplacé le rsa activité
versé aux personnes qui travaillent et
gagnent peu le département
chef de file de l'action sociale est ici
en première ligne le métier essentiel du
département c'est s'occuper précisément
des réunionnais d'abord les prix
modestes et deuxièmement des réunionnais
plus fragiles
je pense aux personnes âgées je pense à
l'enfance une fois qu'on a dit ça
le département de la réunion 1 comme les
autres conseils départementaux métropole
met en place toute une série de
dispositifs j'allais dire pour tenter
d'accompagner d'en sauver le plus grand
nombre comprend bien que le rsa c'est un
minimum pour survivre c'est un petit
pécule
mais on peut pas faire une vie avec ça
une fois le droit au rsa ouvert ce sont
les agents du département qui accueille
les bénéficiaires du rsa dans les
maisons départementales
un rendez vous obligatoire pour définir
un parcours d'insertion que je vous ai
convoqué ce matin face à face la
confiance doit se créer un moment
déterminant où il faut identifier la
situation globale la volonté de l'usager
et ses besoins réels
c'est une analyse dans un premier temps
on essaye d'aller savoir le pourquoi
comment il est arrivé dans ce dispositif
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui l'a amenée
et en fonction des éléments qui va
m'apporter donc je vais pouvoir
justement creuser un peu plus aller un
peu plus loin avec cette personne et
l'amener est amené à lui apporter des
serre-têtes voilà quand démarre
l'insertion des bénéficiaires du rsa au
conseil départemental proposé des
solutions d'insertion aux allocataires
doit rester la priorité
le parcours doit être le plus efficace
et pour ce faire
trois étapes sont possibles l'insertion
durable des allocataires du rsa ne peut
se faire que dans la mesure où les
problématiques sociales importantes en
matière de santé de logement ou de
niveau familial sont réglés une analyse
globale qui passe par des actions de
prévention des plus jeune public avec
des dispositifs tels que l' académie des
dalons ou encore le plan 4000 jeunes une
évolution des chiffres car cette étape
souvent peu visible est pourtant
essentielle pour la suite du parcours
pour cette remise sur pied les agents du
département mobilise tous les acteurs de
l'insertion dans l'intérêt de l'usagé
ouverture de droits à résolution de
frein matériel accompagnement l'objectif
est de donner des solutions
bénéficiaires qui souhaitent
entreprendre cette démarche d'insertion
durable
j'étais l'association glaive en tant que
magazine mécanicien en contraste c'est
lui alors j'ai eu mon bac littéraire
cette année et j'ai décidé de poursuivre
dans la communication parce qu'il ya
autant d'histoires que d'individus les
choix des parcours se doivent être
variés et adaptés selon l'âge
l'expérience les qualifications et les
freins sociaux la collectivité dispose
d'un panel le dispositif qualifiable de
coup de pouce
ainsi les jeunes disposent par exemple
de fonds d'aidé aux jeunes du nouveau
pack jeune citoyen ou encore des
dispositifs tels que le pacte social
territorial cet accompagnement financier
des projets d'insertion des communes
permet l'acquisition de savoir faire qui
sont les prérequis à l'insertion
professionnelle
une première expérience qui peut avoir
lieu également par le biais des c8 cae
ainsi 4000 contrats d'une durée moyenne
de 8 mois couplée un dispositif de
formations sont dispensées par le
département
tous les acteurs sont ici concernés
particulièrement les associations et
structures liées au département elles
seront mobilisés pour accompagner ses
allocataires en insertion moment il faut
s'appeler matane ont envie en ce moment
comme moi l'édifice yonath moment pour
nous iliad à nouveau qu une augmentation
significative pour faire de cette
insertion des bénéficiaires du rsa
le premier palier vers l'emploi
on est à 60 2 à 3 ans de bénévolat ont
été enlevés ça et à proposer - 1 contre
en tant que animateurs périscolaire et
ensuite ma vie que mona hraoui le projet
artisanat en place passée la formation
entre grands technique d'insertion la
personne en recherche d'emploi nous
devons l'accompagner est ce qu elle crée
son propre parcours
'cela ne veut pas ce n'est pas lui dire
vous avez un tel dispositif est rentré
dedans c'est là nous devons accompagner
la personne à avoir son parfum de a
jusqu'à z
c'est à dire z c'est l'emploi pérenne je
crois qu'il faut faire taire parfois les
formules qu'on a tendance à dire on dit
que le réunionnais ils viennent pas trop
entreprenant et moi je crois que les
chiffres nous prouve le contraire
le réunionnais n entreprendre par contre
il a besoin qu'on l'aide d'une entrée
dynamique vers un emploi durable qui
peut passer par la création de sa propre
activité avec un accompagnement des
acteurs du réseau point chance et la
mobilisation des aides telles que
préface aden ou récemment le tage
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes la
politique départementale en matière de
coopération dans la zone océan indien
est également une solution
il s'agit de partager son savoir-faire
et acquérir une expérience
la mobilité en général accompagnés par
le cnam et facteur d'une insertion
durable comme ici avec la grande
distribution du matin ah oui j'adore il
ya une belle vue par ici à boulogne et
cela sur tout le territoire national
avec des dispositifs tels que les
familles d'accueil
chef de file de l'action sociale
l'ambition de la collectivité ne peut en
rester là comment optimiser les
dispositifs afin de les rendre plus
efficaces et comment rassembler tous les
acteurs pour accompagner au plus près
l'usagé dans ce contexte restreint deux
attitudes pour l'avenir subir ou agir
on nous a demandé dans le cadre de
préparation de pdi d'optimiser de
facilité et de revoir les démarches
administratives pour permettre un
parcours plus simple du bénéficiant des
bénéficiaires l'exemple le plus marquant
pour nous acteurs de terrain c'est la
création d'un guichet unique au sein des
maisons départementales qui permettent à
l'usagé de devenir et de trouver une
aide un appui
mais si haut dans sa globalité c'est
presque du sur mesure une intelligence
institutionnels pour une action
efficiente de la collectivité en faveur
de l'insertion ainsi tous les services
du département concours dans un but
commun l'usagé